merci monsieur le président alors grande
insatisfaction
juste une remarque préalable
je fais partie de ces parlementaires qui
quand ils transmettent un courrier il
aimerait bien avoir une réponse écrite
parce que je me rends souvent ça fait
suite à une intervention ou une demande
d'aidé lui et ça nous permet de leur
transmettre la réponse de l'autorité
qu'on sollicite alors grenat
satisfaction puisque et puis à écouter
mes collègues je vois bien que
finalement l'état crée une inégalité au
droit à l'accès à un réseau de
communication dans ce pays moi j'attends
une ambition une ambition de services
une ambition au service de tous les
habitants de ce pays y compris en
territoire rural et on voit bien qu'il
ya une vraie vraie fracture en france
certains parlent de 5g ce matin je peux
vous assurer que je suis l'une à
territoire mais si on avait dû 2g et
demi on serait heureux alors très
concrètement vous avez parlé fibre à un
moment donné je regardais mon collègue
le sénateur favreau ce qu on a été un
petit ensemble présidents de conseils
départementaux et heureusement qu'on a
pas attendu
d'extérieur ce que si les collectivités
s'était pas mêlé de mettre la fibre
partout comme nous l'avons su le faire
en quelques années déjà mais ça ne se
serait fait jamais ça c'est le constat
sur la fibre alors sur la téléphonie
mobile
c'est dramatique peu importe les
pourcentages et les cartes les mesures
on les a vu comment les mesures était
faite
parfois il suffit de trouver un coin
près d'un conteneur au fond d'un village
on a posé trois téléphones par terre ou
un sur un escabeau puis si on ya une
barre on va considérer que le territoire
est couvert
c'est pas ça la réalité tout le monde le
sait bien on est infoutue de passer une
communication téléphonique pour aller
d'un point à un autre quel que soit le
département
donc à un moment donné ça fait 26 ans
que la téléphonie mobile existe sous la
forme qu'on la connaît aujourd'hui et on
est en retard
moi je vais vous emmener si vous voulez
au burkina faso où je vais tous les ans
en mission depuis 20 ans on va à gorom
gorom
sud du mali le téléphone passe on a des
territoires en france où on n'a rien le
gouvernement annonce 5000 pylônes en
janvier 2019
combien aujourd'hui sont posées et en
fonction ça j'attends vraiment qu'une
réponse qui soit publiée dans cette
commission
vous avez une annonce de julien de
normandie en janvier 19 5000 pylônes
combien aujourd'hui la réalité c'est
qu'il faut deux ans dans ce pays pour
autoriser un pylône et vous l'avez dit
vous-même madame je vous cite deux ans
pour le construire
les chinois ont mis dix jours à
construire un hôpital donc et échoué à
belley vous était parlementaire bien
avant moi j'ai j'ai quelques jours
d'expérience madame et et j'ai été un
peu choqué vous aimiez monde et la
responsabilité sur les communes rurales
je pouvais assurer que les maires encore
plus en ruralité
quand ils sont en zone du non accès au
droit de non accès au droit
ils font tout pour que ça marche je peux
mesurer même que l'on voit des fois des
abf qui sont facilitateur parce que on
trouve des solutions
quelles que soient les monuments qu'on a
au bord des villages donc il constate
c'est que l'état deux agences la recette
france mobile et que le résultat
ma question est simple sur les 5000
pylônes annoncé combien sont aujourd'hui
posée combien sont aujourd'hui en
fonction et eau